and I think the red pillow has helped my
relationships with men to be honest like
especially like my dad and my brothers
um like when you
guys I listened to something where they
were talking about how love or respect
is to men as like love is to women and
it just like me and my little brother um
I just used to like the more I like
didn't you know little brother so you
don't always want to listen to him or
take his op you know cuz you're like
you're younger than me but the more I
would like respect his opinion I
realized like I got along better with
him better than everyone else in my
family he's just a bit of a headstrong
you know